hey everybody i'm laura ingram this is
the ingram angle tonight from washington
now last night we explained why obama
intel's our jim clapper
was so testy gosh he was angry
about attorney general bill barr
confirming that the trump campaign
had indeed been spied upon now he wasn't
the only one
and tonight is jim comey's turn in the
barrel
plus the democrats congressional
hearings this week or a farce from
beginning
to end all the embarrassing moments you
know you miss them
and the hilarious clapbacks all coming
up
and raymond arroyo is here so what's
behind mayor pete's religious war
against vice president pence
don't get it and screwy louis farrakhan
forgot
what funeral he was attending
all that more in a special holy edition
of friday follies
but first in our ingram angle we can
review
some stories you may have missed now
first we hit immigration
now the left has a very interesting way
of approaching this issue
it's not an emergency is it when 100 000
people are pouring across our southern
border
but when it's reported that president
trump is considering bussing
illegal immigrant detainees to sanctuary
cities
well the democrats totally freak out the
president
upped the ante today we can give them a
lot we can give them an unlimited supply
and let's see if they're so happy they
say we have open arms they're always
saying they have open arms let's see if
they have open arms
well now the president may have legal
standing to make good on this threat and
look at how the democrats are squirming
now
nancy pelosi said the extent of this
administration's cynicism
and cruelty cannot be overstated
but wait wait wait a second shouldn't
she and her other california politicians
ones are all for open borders shouldn't
they be thrilled
they are the ones after all who have
said this about sanctuary cities
in our sanctuary cities our people are
not disobeying
the law so it's not a question of giving
sanctuary to
someone who has a uh is guilty of a
crime
the fact is sanctuary cities keep people
safer they keep people healthier
and they keep people educated gosh i
mean that's just a commercial for
sanctuary cities take them in bring them
in welcome the men
but it's not so simple is it consider
this horrific crime
in the sanctuary city of jersey city
an illegal alien is charged in the march
24th rape and murder
of jogger carolina cano jorge rios had
been deported two times from the united
states
before returning illegally a third time
now kano worked as a nanny and friends
say she was an incredible woman
of strong faith and a beautiful giving
heart
but the left doesn't even acknowledge
these american tragedies
they're too busy trying to demonize
trump on this and score
political points which brings us to our
next story
this week democrats continued flailing
in the wake of bob mueller's no
collusion finding
now i think they're beyond desperate at
this point to regain political footing
after
two years of leveling defamatory and
false accusations against the president
remember he was basically
spooning with vladimir putin before the
election but they've quickly found a new
target
attorney general bill barr his
credibility will be absolutely shredded
if he fails to retract
this assertion he lost whatever credible
credibility he may have had
the chief law enforcement officer of our
country
is going off the rails the attorney
general feels that it's his job to do
the president's bidding
now watching barr at the hearings this
week
flick off all of their insipid comments
and inquiries
one by one i've got to say i watched
every minute
of all these hearings and with barr it
was better than anything on netflix
the media though of course joined the
liberals
bar crawl looking for any buzz they
could get
this guy's on a tight rope on one side
he wants to lean one way to make sure
trump keeps him in the job and the other
way
don't look like an ass you can almost
see his mind
bar going okay how do i answer this
question
so trump doesn't tweet at me
so i keep my job
but still not making jackass of myself
for life that's tough you know what's
tough
this obvious thought afraid to lose his
job
you mean go back to a comfortable no
stress retirement and enjoy his
grandkids
are you kidding me why would bill barr
do something unethical today in order to
save a job
he already had 30 years ago news flash
he doesn't need
to build his resume kids
yet the moment that sent shivers down
the spines of the former obama deep
staters
was this one i think spying
on a political campaign is a big deal
yes i think spying did occur
and i'm not suggesting it wasn't
adequately predicated but i need to
explore that
well i wondered how former fbi chief jim
comey felt upon hearing that spying
reference
look this is terrible it makes me mildly
nauseous to think that we might have had
some impact on the election
well it turns out that former spooks was
something to hide
practice the art of deflection and then
they play word games spying has
a a term i've never liked i never
liked that term being applied to me it
has a bad connotation it's a pejorative
term i really don't know what he's
talking about
when he talks about spying on the
campaign the fbi and the department of
justice
conduct court ordered electronic
surveillance i have never thought of
that as spying
[Music]
so let me get this straight clapper and
comey otherwise known as jim squared
that's what we call him here
were the guys determined to get
something on president trump both
through
surveillance and leaking the media
but now they're spending their time
quibbling with the term spying
now this concern which is all phony over
semantics
of course it reeks of desperation i
think the real fear
is that attorney general barr is
extremely serious
he's very judicious extremely
professional and he's on the case
and they also know that the inspector
general mike horowitz
will not only clean up this mess but
hold those who perpetrated this
fraud accountable